جماهير اسبانيا تهاجم برشلونه وما قصه
الساعه في غرفه ملابس ارسنال وحارس
الارجنتيني يبيع قفاز المونديال هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
عبر مدرب برشلونه
بسبب الاجواء العدائيه على حد تعبيره التي
عاشها فريقه خلال مباراه اتلتيكو بلباو
حيث وجه البعض من جماهير بلباو هتافات
معاديه تجاه فريق برشلونه يقولون يقولون
فيها الى الدرجه الثانيه وتاتي هذه
الرتافات بسبب القضيه التحكيميه التي تحيط
بالفريق الكتلوني في الوقت الحالي
حمله الهجوم على برشلونه وصلت ايضا الى
جماهير نادي اشبيليه التي تركت احداث
مباراه فريقها ضد الميريا وتفرغت للهجوم
على رفاق بوسكيت وذلك برفع العملات ورقيه
من فئه 100 يورو لكنها تحتوي على صوره
لابورتا رئيس نادي برشلونه في كنايه عن
رشوه الحكام
بعد فوز ارسنال على فولان بالدوري
الانجليزي احتفل نجوم المدفعجيه في غرفه
الملابس وهم يحملون مجسما لساعه حائط
كبيره وهي نسخه مقلده من الساعه الموجوده
في ملعب الامارات لجعل غرفه الملابس
الخاصه بالفريق تبدو وكانها ملعب الامارات
حتى لو لم تكن مباراه على ارضهم
في لفته الانسانيه بيعت قفازات حارس مرمى
الارجنتين ايميليان ومارتينيز والتي
ارتداها خلال رحلات الترجيح الحاسمه في
مونديال قطر بيعت في مزاد مقابل 45 الف
دولار امريكي لمساعده مرضى مستشفى سرطان
الاطفال
[موسيقى]